cinéma si vous avez envie de rire
n'hésitez pas à voir les deux mondes un
film de daniel cohen qui tient surtout
sur son acteur principal benoît
poelvoorde
il y incarne un petit artisan parisiens
qui se retrouvent propulsés dans un
autres vont par l'intermédiaire d'une
faille espace temps dans sa vie réelle
il est un peu à l'étroit dans l'autre
c'est un dieu vivant christophe airaud
france brille c'est ce soir là dans la
cuisine familiale la vie de rim bassano
bascule ou plutôt s'enfonce dans
l'absurde
il y aurait sous la terre une peuplade à
main qu'il rejoint par accident en train
de rêver de départ et elle apparaît elle
est là c'est le début des ennuis les
deux mondes c'est une comédie lions
fantastique et rigolades film de potash
le deuxième film de daniel cohen et sa
première rencontre avec benoît
poelvoorde histoire permettait d'avoir
ce ressort comique d'un type donc banale
qui vivent des choses extraordinaires
qui ne peut raconter à personne puisque
pour un fou donc il faut que vivre ça en
secret au lithium
dans un monde où la boue on estime pour
l'asp est consterné devant lui comment
un homme normal réagir et par rapport à
ça il prendrait ses jambes à son cou du
toujours prévu de mettre un gros coup
dans la tronche joueurs très costauds
puis neuville courir mais il faut savoir
courir vite
coincé entre les deux mondes dans la
vrai dire aimer batinova craquer et
péter un câble on savait faire quoi je
sais pas je travaille dans le bâtiment
je voulais dire ça c'est important je
vous ai demandé de me dire tout mon
diplôme j'ai fait construire une ville
une ville quoique sérieux son
centre-ville c'est vrai que c'est pas si
facile pour monsieur tout le monde de
faire croire qu'il est le roi du monde
politique